こんにちは はじめしゃちょーです
あの動画のタイトル見てもわかると思う んですけども
ちょっと不思議なことが起きまして
あの今日はそれについてお話しようと思います
あの私はじめしゃちょー
YouTuberやらしていただいておりまして
こんな私にもありがたいことに
ファンという者がいてくれております
えー、ファンの皆さん
いつもありがとな、愛してるぜ！
という話をしたいのではなくて
プレゼントとか手紙をよくいただきます
本当にあのくださる方いつもありがとう ございます
あの時間がある時にちょっと
いろいろ見たりしてはいるんですけども
その 中である人から
毎日、毎日手紙が送られてきているんです
すごくないですか
なんか手紙よくもらっ たりするんですけど
毎日送る方ってい なくて
で一応こちらにあるんですけども
ちゃんとuuumに僕宛で送ってくださっております
すごいですね
いやもうすごい ポイントその１は
毎日ちゃんと送るところだと思います
継続は力なりと言います
いつも お手紙 ありがとうございます
ちなみにこの毎日の手紙いつから来ているかといいますと
3 月の15日今年に入ってからですね
今年の3月から
ずーっと手紙を毎日送っていただいておりました
本当にすごい量の手紙をいただいております
ではまず記念すべき1枚目見ていきましょう
あのー
内容は
シンプルですいたってシンプル
てか詩人です
詩人と言うべきか分から ないんですけど も
とりあえず見せ ましょうまず最初に届い た手紙こちら
はい
今日
誕生日なんです
自分へのプレゼントとしてアバのパーカーを買います
俺じゃないんかい俺じゃないん
アバンティーズなん？ん？
どういうことだ
まあ誕生日だった んでしょうね
おめでとうございます
ただアバンティーズのパーカー買うの
何故俺に言う？
謎は深まるばかりです次行きましょう
次の日のお手紙はコチラですね
私の少女時代のバイブルリボンでタバコ 描写がNGに
信じられない厳しくない何でも規制規制
それでは聴いてください
R指定で規制中
俺関係なくない？
まぁそうですよね世の中いろいろ規制が多くなってきますよ ね
本当に僕は
でもR指定の曲めちゃくちゃ聴くわけでもないし
リボンもわからないしタバコも吸わないし
あの関係なくね？俺
謎は深まるばかりです。次に行き ましょう こちら
おぉはじメーノへの入会してみました
ありがとうございます！
ありがとう待てたよー
やばくね
3枚目の手紙にしてようやく僕に 関係することが出てきたという
後なんか字が凄いきれいというか独特なんですよ ね
ちょっと相田みつをさんを連想される感じです ね
って言うのがめっちゃ続くんですよ
どんどん 行き ましょう
35歳なんて恥ずかしくて外歩け ない
35歳 なんですかね
わかんない年齢はわからない
これがまずこの方のことを言ってるかわかんないんですけど
35歳そんなことないですよ
全然外あるけますよは35歳でも
35歳なのかな
僕はあの全然ファンの方とか年齢全然気にしてないんで
これからもよろしくお願いします
35歳なのかなあ
あの関係ないことたくさん送ってくださるので
35歳っていうワードが出たからといって
この方が35 歳とは限らないんですよ
謎は深まるばかりです
続いてこちらです
人はなぜ旅行前夜になって慌てて準備を始めるのか
え？私だけ終わらんパスポートどこ～
旅行に行かれるんですねどこに行ったんでしょう か
あの僕あんまり旅行とか興味ないんで
全然行き たいとかそういう欲はないんです けど
お仕事で海外行く時とかパスポートをなくし ますよね
良い旅になり ますように
俺関係なくね？
今5枚読んだんですけど 関係あるのファンクラブ入りましただけですよ
ええっどういうことだ
ちょ、どんどん読んでいきましょう
続いてはこちらです
ただいま。現実。何があったんでしょう
佐賀空港の駐車場が無料なのが本当に助かる
佐賀県な んですかね
いや分かりませんよ
佐賀空港の駐車場は無料らしいです皆さんご活用ください
これなんてもう
ついにデカキンとヒカキンのセイキンの対面
なるほど
セイキンさんと正気をかけ てるんですね
俺関係な
はいって言うのがもう毎日毎日送ってもらってるんです僕！
すごいっすよやろうと思ってできることじゃないですよこれ
あぁすごい絵も書いて下さったりしてます ありがとう ございます
おー すげー
Yoしばらく見てない財布
警察には届いてない様子
中にはポイントカードを数々
誰かに使われるときはそう楽々
クレカ、テレカ、ニモカ
今どこにあるのかな教えてくれよああ神様yeah～
ラップも書けるんですね
はじめしゃちょーpontaカード1万ポイントもすごいですが
Tカードに240万ポイントも入っ てる方が いらっしゃい ました
えええ
不正入手したんじゃないか疑ってる んすね
いやぁ分かります
いや日本もそうですよ黒いマスクつけてる人見 たら僕まだちょっと不自然に思いますもん
いやわかるわかりますその気持ち
ボタニカル使うとなんかね僕も抜け毛酷くなったんですよね一時期
いやいやいやいやもうみつをよ
楽チンだものはみつをですよもう
あーっとあついいただき まし たーーー！
えぇもうただのポストカードやんけ
あぁ素敵な旅館ああ
そうかお泊りさ れ た んですね
はいっていうのをですねもうずーっと送ってくださるわけですよ
確かにねほんとにもう僕に関係 ないこととか何でも書いてくれるんですよね
はいという感じでほぼ毎日
手紙送ってくださる方がいます
はいというわけですねあの
あの正直最初はちょっと何 なんだろうって言うかなんか不思議だったんであの
こんだけ毎日書いていただけるとなんかすごい逆に
なんかすごい
いいですね
面白いのがファンレターとかじゃなくて
ほんとになんかもうほんと相田みつをさんの詩ではないですけど
あったこととか思ったこととかただただ送ってくださる方だったんで
何だろうあの
すごいなぁと思ってあの動画にさせていただきました
すい ませ んあの、あの嫌ですとかじゃないんで
ほんと楽しませていただいているのであの
これ からも ぜひ送ってくださるとありがたいです
すごいよね
何か手紙の在り方を
考えさせられるなと思いましたこういうのなんか
何気 ないことを送ってくる人そうそうい ないですからね！？
ほんとちょっと不思議だなぁと思って
動画にさせていただいたんですけども
あのちょっと僕はこういう手紙もらって
ほっこりしたなって思いました
よかった怖い人じゃなくて
すごい楽しませていただいているんで
これからもぜひお手紙のほうお待ちしております
何がすごいかっていうとねこういうこと
毎日続けることがすごい なと思いました
どんな些細なことでも毎日
続けれる事って本当にすごいと思うので
これからもお待ちしておりますじゃな
すげーいい動画になっちゃった